this is the equation that you can't give
it and the simple question is find dy/dx
when you look at it all of the X's and
Y's are kind of tangled up together
which is what makes it a perfect
candidate for a plis is differentiation
okay
I'll remind you if pussied
differentiation just a fancy name for
the change
okay so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
going to take this I'm gonna take every
single term and I'm going to
differentiate with respect to X not
gonna rearrange I'm just gonna take it
as is okay just take it really clear
what I'm doing I'm going to write the
differential operator at the front of
every single one of my terms
no exceptions okay when people do
implicit differentiation often more
things they forget is that they need to
differentiate everything even I would
say especially the constants right
that's gonna make your odds are
different if you don't differentiate
them but we're so used to thinking on
cuz it doesn't matter when your
different chain well you have to make
sure you cut for them so you can see
what I've written here everything is
being differentiated all five times some
of them are easy and some of them other
to walk quickly so you have a look let's
start over here on the left the
derivative with respect to X of x cubed
that's an easy one okay I can see
another couple of easy ones over there
but I'll get to them in due time
I want you have a look at this guy okay
you're differentiating Y cubed and Y is
a function of X right I don't know what
function of X it is but it is a function
of X so all I do is chain rule on that
I'll do the inside and I'll do the
outside okay actually since it's more
conveniently I'll do the outside first
okay whatever this function is it's
something raised to a power
right so the power is going to climb
down the front and then it's going to
reduce by work that's the outside
what's the
the inside it's just doing yeah right
like the inside function is y and then
you raise it to a power that's the
outside part so this is going to get
multiplied by DUI the X plus or hi
so I have one instance of this then you
have a look at this guy
okay careful this is a product isn't it
this is a product between one function
namely 2x and another function namely Y
I mean actually it doesn't really matter
I can throw that two out the front
actually I will do that so be it this is
a product this times that I'm going to
use product rule one so I have my two
which I just brought up what we usually
have this as UV - that's why u and V and
at reviews vu decimals you be - why is
my V right so I'm gonna go
why - that's why - right times youth +
this is all around you which is this guy
oh I didn't reverse on it but sorry I
guess I can just keep going
so this should be 1
my not confuse myself my stocking v:u -
plus you read - that's better
I just did it reversal are you happy
with that static a product or table and
then you get to easy parts that's a
constant differential since 0 and
there's another constant also different
O's ok happy times
yeah what is it that I'm after Eli I
want to IDX and all that means here is
just rearrange a bit be patient with
yourself and change the subject
there it is tangled up in a couple of
spots all I need to do is get all the
dy/dx terms on the left and then I'll be
able factorize and get everything else
on the right ok what can you see that I
could get over to the right-hand side
easily this guy I can get rid of
anything else
yeah good you're that guy ok so
immediately I'm gonna take it over to
the right-hand side of the equation
something like that oh my god - 3 x
squared minus 2y oh God and that leaves
me with two terms and how do you win the
X on them ok what are the two terms plus
two times X so what I need to do now I'm
pretty I'm pretty much there yeah I need
to get dy on DX on its own make it the
subject that means here I've got this
sky numerator and this guy on the
denominator what do you think admittedly
it is somewhat messy but then again it's
exactly the kind of messy you would
expect out of what we started with right
all those X's and Y's are tangled up you
can see it's also symmetrical in x and y
right do you see if I swap all the X's
with wise right so all the externalize
you end up with the same equation which
is what you see in the derivative almost
right you'd have the inverse if you stop
[ __ ] around but has just the right
amount of symmetry that I expect it's
tangled mess but then again that's
if I were to do something with this and
they don't even don't know what kind of
shape this is it's some kind of relation
obviously I'm expecting it's a kind of
relation and in order to find the
derivative at the point you're gonna
need the X and the y that's why that's
to me that's what you do okay
any questions mirror modules what's that
this is not the coming to discussion
okay so we have a complex number I put
it over here okay I'm sorry that's a bad
place to put it if that's what a complex
number is that's the modulus to do the
complex number now assuming the complex
number has some kind of ability to move
its variable its try see on an office of
some kind then the modules will change
so I won't be smallest the modules can
be where's the smallest ways like my
closest it can be yeah so for example ok
he's an actual question but what would
be the equation all
what would the equation of that page
could you work out that's that's a
circle man right how would you state the
equation of that yes there's enough
information there isn't that the radius
is going to be okay so you're thinking
so there are two there are two different
ways that our company you think about
this they can you're thinking cartesian
terms so you're thinking of this as a Y
at an x axis which isn't completely
wrong just wrong I would then say the
center of my circle is is 2 comma 0 so I
guess it's gonna be X minus 2 all
squared plus y squared equals okay
that's a Cartesian way of thinking about
it there's another way I can think about
it I can think about it just in terms of
modulus in terms of the clapping subong
right so I would say measuring from here
right is just said okay but here I've
shifted over that way okay so here is Z
minus 2 I've gone to the right and then
I want the distance to Z minus 2 the
distance distance prongs n minus 2 I
want it to be I want to be radius in a
certain line right so these are both the
equations of that locket okay now coming
back to the question the question was
what's the minimum modulus of Z and this
question it's pretty obvious it's one
that's the closest you can possibly get
butt-fucked up the circle somewhere else
weird then it might be a little more
complicated to find out